justice politique police des éléments
constitutifs d'une république
démocratique et juste quand les pouvoirs
sont séparés et correctement exercés
mais quand ceci converge on court le
risque de voir apparaître une justice
politique où la volonté du pouvoir tant
à utiliser les procédures judiciaires à
des fins politiques
une définition qui pourrait s'appliquer
à la situation actuelle à du dossier
souvient bref rappel des faits le 3
janvier 2020 cédric joue via est victime
d'un malaise cardiaque
aux abords de la tour eiffel après avoir
été plaqué au sol
car ce que sur la tête par trois
policiers au terme d'un contrôle routier
tendu deux jours plus tard il meurt
d'une asphyxie avec fracture du larynx
en juillet 2020 l'enquète a conduit les
juges d'instruction à mettre en examen
et placé sous contrôle judiciaire pour
homicide involontaire trois des quatre
fonctionnaires impliqués dans ce
contrôle routier qui a dégénéré
les avocats de la famille ont par
ailleurs réclamé la suspension de ces
policiers en décembre dernier demande
qui s'est vu adresser une fin de non
recevoir de la part du ministre de
l'intérieur
dans un courrier adressé à la famille le
21 juin dernier les premiers éléments de
l'enquète n'ont pu permet d'établir que
les fonctionnaires avaient commis lors
de l'interpellation de monsieur chou via
un manquement à leurs obligations tel
qui soit susceptible de justifier d'une
mise à l'écart de leurs services ainsi
pour gérald darmanin la mort d'un homme
ne justifie pas la mise à l'écart d'un
fonctionnaire de police dont la
responsabilité est potentiellement
engager une prise de position qui pose
question dans la sphère éclair à du nom
de ce producteur tabassé par des
policiers en novembre 2020
le ministre de l'intérieur avait jugé
qu'il était de son devoir de suspendre
les policiers mis en cause la famille
shaw via ne comprends pas cette
différence de traitement
en effet sur ces images on peut voir
clairement les policiers exerçant une
pression sur cédric joue via plaqué au
sol et alors qu'ils savent fixe y est
sous le poids des policiers il avait
alerté à plus de sept reprises en leur
criant j'étouffe et ce n'est pas tout
l'igpn
dans une note du 17 juin 2020 relate un
autre point concernant la technique
d'appréhension a mis en oeuvre par les
policiers alors que trois des quatre
policiers ont poursuivi leur pression
sur son dos
l'un d'entre eux semblé lui pratiquer un
étranglement arrière à l'occasion duquel
il avait au moins une fois exercer une
traction sur sa gorge conduisant à une
compromission momentanée de l'axé tête
coûteront la fameuse clé d'étranglement
dont christophe castaner avait annoncé
l'abandon il ya un an et qui vient
d'être remplacé par des techniques
issues du judo principalement
responsable dans cette affaire a en
croit le compte rendu de l'igpn
quoi qu'il en soit cette décision de
gérald darmanin semble incompréhensible
le ministre de l'intérieur se justifie
d'une autre manière pour éviter une
suspension est d'après lui les
fonctionnaires n'auraient jamais été
impliqué dans des faits de violences
illégitimes durant leur carrière
affirmation fausse le principal
policiers mis en cause michael p a fait
l'objet d'un signalement auprès de
l'igpn conduisant à une enquête
judiciaire pour violences en avril 2018
les avocats de la famille de cédric joue
via dénonce une culture du lait cette
fin de non-recevoir ne peut s'analyser
autrement que comme la négation de la
réalité de cette affaire et des
aspirations de la famille elle résonne
comme un cruel dédain à l'égard de ceux
ayant perdu un père un mari un fils un
frère une suspension ne ramènera pas
monsieur cédric joue via mais à l
inverse
son absence rend son décès encore plus
inexplicable et intolérable la famille
shaw via fais confiance à la justice
mais pour combien de temps encore telle
est la question